what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and some unexpected news
has recently come to light as it turns
out Avengers the Kang Dynasty might not
all be what exactly you expect it to be
now we've talked a little bit on the
channel about what we expect it to be
but now that the writer for Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania and the King
Dynasty Jeff loveness has spoken up
about what to expect it kind of changes
our view of what we are going to be
getting in the Kang Dynasty also there
has been some news that we are going to
be getting some major Phase 5 and phase
six delays now we were expecting some
delays before we've talked about it a
few times however we really weren't
expecting them to the extent that might
actually happen now as always like I've
said with delays this is both good and
bad the fact that things are getting
delayed sucks but the reason that
they're getting delayed is good they are
trying to improve and make things better
so a lot to dive into in today's video
and if you love Marvel and you like to
stay up to date with everything in the
MCU be sure to subscribe to the channel
now we'll start with the delays because
I know a lot of people get really
concerned about this the newest report
about these delays is coming from Alex P
over at thecosmiccircus.com and they've
been pretty accurate with their Scoops
lately and the first thing that Alex
tweeted was Marvel Studios is taking the
term spring cleaning very seriously huh
and posted a picture of the entire Phase
5 slate with everything kind of windexed
out removed except for Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania of course because we
already have that in theaters right now
and Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. the
next Marvel Studios movie that is set to
hit theaters so with this tweet we
already started to assume that yes there
were indeed going to be some delays
maybe even some shuffling of certain
projects now assuming what some people
mean online is sometimes kind of tricky
however there is a follow-up tweet
somebody asked why what got pushed now
and which Alex replied the character
limit doesn't let me list at all it is
easier for me to say what won't get
pushed Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. so
this heavily implies if this report is
true that the entire Phase 5 slate
except for what we've gotten so far
quantumania and what we're about to get
Guardians 3 is going to be pushed back
we are going to be getting some delays
and Marvel Studios is President Kevin
feige kind of already confirmed this
before he didn't directly tell us that
there were going to be some delays
however he did say this I do think one
of the powerful aspects of being at
Marvel Studios is having these films and
shows hit the Zeitgeist it is harder to
hit the Zeitgeist when there's so much
product out there and so much content as
they say which is a word I hate but we
want Marvel Studios and the MCU projects
to really stand out and stand above so
people will see that as we get further
into phase 5 and 6 the pace at which
we're putting out Disney Plus shows will
change so they can each get a chance to
shine so Kevin feige already confirmed
it right there in Phase 5 and phase six
the pace at which they're putting out
shows is going to change and to top it
all off when he was asked whether this
change of pace means spacing out the
releases of shows or releasing fewer
shows a year Kevin feige said both I
think so now the fact that we are
getting reports that Phase 5 is kind of
going to be completely changed as far as
scheduling is concerned it doesn't come
as that big of a surprise but it also
doesn't come as extremely bad news
because as Kevin feige said here the
focus here in shifting things around is
to make their projects really stand out
and stand above so they are focusing on
quality now hopefully these changes mean
that they're just going to get pushed
back a little bit and not nothing too
drastic we already kind of expected and
there's been a rumor going around that
Loki and secret Invasion are going to be
the only two Disney plus Marvel shows
that we are going to be getting this
year hopefully that still stands true
because both both of these shows are
going to be very important for the
future of the MCU since Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is the last movie in the
trilogy and essentially James Gunn's
goodbye and some of the other Guardians
goodbye as well we're assuming that this
movie is kind of going to stand alone
and not have that big of a connection if
any with the rest of the projects that
are happening of course since it's in
the MCU it'll tie in one way or another
however I think the film is the final
goodbye for the Guardians and stands
alone which is why I think the schedule
release for it has not changed that and
it is the next upcoming Marvel film now
a phase 5 is getting delayed
unfortunately Phase 6 is going to get
delayed as well but again just trying to
look at the bright side here hopefully
that means that Marvel Studios is going
to be releasing better projects when
they do release them it is also very
important to note that Alex from the
cosmic circus did say that nothing is
getting canceled simply delayed and of
course if we hear anything about this
we'll be sure to do an update video but
going on into the Kang Dynasty like I
mentioned Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania writer Jeff loveness is also
going to be writing the Kang Dynasty and
right now he's doing a lot of interviews
about Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
but of course people are taking this
opportunity to also ask him about Kang
Dynasty and he may just be being
secretive but if he's not he dropped an
unfortunate bomb on us when asked about
what it's like riding the next Avengers
movie this is what he said yeah it's
definitely a tricky thing but much like
when I took on this Ant-Man job I can't
really focus on that outside stuff he
said speaking about other movies that
are involved in the MCU he continued to
say I have just got to lay down the
bones of a good story hopefully and find
the characters that I want to tell it
and then it becomes a game of ping pong
with other people like whoever comes on
and does Fantastic Four or blade I'm
probably not even using those characters
you know but it all informs itself and
so you just keep an open ear if someone
says hey if blade wants to jump jump in
go for it man but it's up to me to focus
on my movie and you know work with
Michael Waldron a little bit about his
thing and Michael Waldron of course is
writing Secret Wars and I happen to know
that Michael Waldron and Jeff loveness
are good friends I talked to Michael
Waldron after Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania I asked him if he knew a lot
about what the movie was going to be
about because he didn't write it but he
said yes because he was really tight
with Jeff so hopefully the two of them
will work really well together but going
back to the unfortunate statement that
Jeff loveness said he said he's probably
not going to be using the Fantastic Four
in the Kang Dynasty now we know the
Fantastic Four movie comes out before
the King Dynasty so we all kind of
expected them to be in it however the
Kang dynasty really is going to be an
Avengers film it's not really going to
involve the Multiverse that much that is
they're not really going to leave the
main MCU universe and it's most likely
going to be just the new Avengers team
fighting one variant or maybe a couple
of King in their Universe protecting
their specific Earth and universe
basically from what we've heard so far
is that Avengers the King Dynasty is
still going to be kind of grounded then
the movies in between the King Dynasty
and Secret Wars are going to start to
explore the Multiverse and then of
course Secret Wars is going to primarily
take place from what we've heard in the
Multiverse in different universes in
different worlds seeing multiple
different Heroes and their variants
which is going to be really really cool
but that's when we can assume the
Fantastic Four gets involved in between
the Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars in fact
I'm sure Mr Fantastic the world's
smartest man alive Reed Richards is
going to play a major role in helping
all of the heroes be able to travel
through different multiverses his
technology along with America Chavez's
powers are probably going to be how The
Avengers actually are able to Multiverse
travel but as of right now don't expect
the Fantastic Four to show up in the
King Dynasty now of course he could just
be saying this to mislead us so there
are no spoilers but luckily for us we do
get the Fantastic Four movie before the
King Dynasty so maybe then we'll get a
little bit more of clarity of how King
Dynasty and Secret Wars are going to
play out but hey let me know what you
think about all of this news in the
comments down below about the delays and
about the Fantastic Four probably not
appearing in the Kang Dynasty if all
your thoughts and theories in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all the latest MCU news
you can also follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof